mr. president what about technology what
what are you looking specifically for
technology to solve the biggest
challenges that you see in government
but I'll distinguish between government
adapting technology to do a better job
which has been a major focus of mine
since I came into office and frankly
we've just scratched the surface whether
it's encouraging people to vote or
dislodging big data so that people can
use it more easily or getting their
forms processed online more simply but
there's there's a huge amount of work to
drag the federal government and state
governments and local governments into
the 21st century it's interesting that
when I talked to friends in Silicon
Valley some of whom I've recruited them
to come into the administration I'm able
to show fairly rapidly what I've said to
them when they're on the outside the gap
between the talent in the federal
government and the private sector is
actually not wide at all they're really
smart people who work really hard here
and are passionate about what they do
the technology gap is massive it when I
when I first got here and I always
imagined like the Situation Room would
be this super cool thing and be like Tom
Cruise and the Minority Report and we'd
be meddling around stuff and I'd have
all these it's not like that at all at
you know the movies I think display
particularly when it comes to hunting
down terrorists on the other side of the
globe display this this omniscience that
we possess somehow and it's just not
bear yet
and it's been drastically underfunded
not properly designed so there's a whole
bunch of work we have to do around
getting government to be more customer
friendly and to make it at least as easy
as ordering a pizza or you know an
airline ticket for you to be able to
file your taxes for example but I think
in terms of the broader questions around
technology I've talked about
individualized medicine and health and
generally energy is obviously massive I
am a firm believer that if we get
climate change right if we're able to
tap the brakes and figure out how we
avoid six foot rise in the oceans that
you manage known figure stuff out I'm
pretty optimistic if we don't get it
right I'm worried and we've done a lot
of good work but there's just an
enormous amount of work still to be done
and to deploy analytical tools and
computing to crack the code around clean
energy we've made progress but we've got
a long way to go and then as I indicated
before and this is to use Joy's term a
meta problem I think figuring out the
structure of regulating connectivity in
the Internet in a way that is
accountable transparent safe allows us
to isolate and get at the bad guys but
ensures that the government does not
possess so much power
in all of our lives that becomes a tool
for oppression
you know we were still working on that
and some of those are technological
problems some of them are legal problems
and a problem shaping the right
architecture politically and illegally
to create mechanisms for accountability
but you know so some of it is is
actually just a tough set of technology
problems that encryption being a good
example where you know I've met with
civil libertarians and national security
people over and over and over again and
it's actually a knotty problem nobody
can give me a really good answer in
terms of how we reconcile some of these
issues so so I think that there's going
to be exciting times that here's one
thing I can guarantee there's stuff I
haven't even thought of yet and I guess
since this is a frontiers issue the last
thing I should mention is you know I'm
still a big space guy and figuring out
how to move into the next generation of
space travel is something that we're
significantly underfunding there's some
good work being done by the private
sector again because increasingly it's
displaced government funding on some of
the what the heck why not ventures crazy
ideas but you know when we think about
space flight we're still thinking about
basically the same chemical reactions we
were back in the Apollo flights 50 years
later it seems like we should be yeah I
don't know if you know lithium crystals
are out there but you know we should be
getting some breakthroughs on that front